[Applause]
fear is for the long night when the Sun
hides for years and children are born
and live and die all in darkness that is
the time for fear my little Lord when
the White Walkers moved through the
woods what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight update video I have some
new photos to show you that we're taking
at the Winterfell said in Northern
Ireland
these did come out a few days ago but I
decided to wait and talk about them
today because I've been having some
trouble trying to record the audio the
last couple days for some reason my
voice has been completely shot and I'm
not sure why because I don't feel sick I
tried to record this last night but like
I said my vocal cords were too sore to
try but hopefully I can get through this
today so let's get started the photos
I'm gonna talk about today are
compliments of oakley photography they
were able to get some new photos of the
aftermath at Winterfell as we all know
this has been one of the most active
filming locations these past few weeks
but it does appear like they are just
about done filming in Winterfell for the
last time which does make me kind of sad
but at least we have some new details to
speculate over these images show the
Winterfell castle in the battlements and
once again it's very clear that
Winterfell was under attack so far the
production crew has done a very good job
at hiding exactly who has been attacking
the stark home but if you zoom in on
some of the photos there may be some
more evidence that can tell us who was
fighting in the north
two of these photos has some interesting
details in them but the only problem is
some of the evidence points to the night
king being here and some of the evidence
may suggest it wasn't the night king
that was here so let's take a look
because I am curious to see what some of
you have to say about these new
developments first let's take a look at
the stack of dead bodies laying outside
the castle wall when you zoom in on this
photo you can see they are wearing the
unsullied uniforms but the more time I
spend looking at this photo
appears to me that some of these
unsullied men are burnt to a crisp and
that wouldn't make much sense because
Daenerys should not be burning her own
men unless this is the night Kings
handiwork the night King could have
burnt them with his dragon or the night
king turned them into whites and
Daenerys had to burn them to kill them
for good there may be some other
evidence that backs this up because the
report came out a few weeks ago and it
said the Hound was actually seen
fighting men dressed up as and solid and
that wouldn't make much sense either
because the Hound is on there same team
unless those men and on solid uniforms
were turned into whites when I first
glanced at this photo I thought maybe
these men just had a darker complexion
like grey worm does but in my opinion it
does look like their faces are burnt I
know some of you may be thinking well if
they were burned by a dragon shouldn't
they have turned into ash or dust yes
that is true
but they will have to do that in
post-production by using some kind of
CGI if they did in fact get burned alive
I guess another explanation could be
they were burnt by wildfire because I
know some people have said that is a
possibility as well which it is possible
but I don't think that's what it is my
guess would be a dragon because all
three dragons will be in the north at
the same time and I just have a very
good feeling the night king will attack
Winterfell
instead of bypassing it this must be a
big target for the night king especially
since brain and Jon will be here the
night king has had too many interactions
with them for him to just pass them by
but that's just my opinion let's take a
closer look at this other photo though
this one shows the castle walls and some
of its defensive weapons but if you zoom
in right here you can see what looks to
be blood and guts all over the wall I
noticed that when some of you tagged me
in these photos you said the army of the
Dead can't be involved in this battle
because there is blood everywhere and as
we know whites and white walkers do not
bleed but you have to keep in mind there
will be stark men standing on those
walls and when the enemy attempts to
breach those walls they will be fighting
whoever is defending them and those men
standing guard will bleed like a stuffed
pig
so I did want to say this blood is most
likely going to come from the man
standing at their post here but then
again you could be right as well this
blood could come from whoever is trying
to get over those walls and if that's
the case it's probably not going to be
White's or white walkers but I think the
burnt bodies and the images of the
castle being on fire suggests that this
will be an attack from the night game I
do have a few other photos but they're
not as interesting I'm sure by now most
of you are aware that they have been
building a gigantic set at titanic
studios and all these new structures are
going to be used for scenes that depict
King's Landing reports also came out a
few months ago that said they did
practice lighting things on fire here
which means these buildings will most
likely be burned to the ground if that's
true we will see fire in King's Landing
next season whether it's Dragon Fire or
wild fire is still up for debate but
it's most likely going to be Dragon Fire
based on what Daenerys saw at the house
of the undying since only the roof is
burnt it has to be from a dragon because
wildfire typically explodes like a bomb
in this building wouldn't be standing
anymore if that was wildfire I do have
to say the contractors did a hell of a
job at constructing this new set this
new structure does look beautiful and it
would be a shame if something had to
happen to it
I don't have much more to add that I
already haven't said in previous videos
so I think this is a good place to end
this video I want to thank everyone for
stopping by to check out this quick
update video let me know what you think
about those first two photos do you
think that is blood from the enemies and
do you think those unsullied men will
burn alive I'd like to know what you
think about those two photos
specifically I think those details can
shed a brighter light on what's actually
happening in the north but your guess is
as good as mine because the details are
still pretty vague but let me know
either way one last thing I also have to
thank everyone on patreon that supports
my channel during this long night I
appreciate each and every one of you
have a good day everyone I'll see you
soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
you